une ex star de disney reconverti dans le
porno rumeurs parues moeurs etc star de
disney il a beaucoup les experts de
disney c'est à britney spears miley
cyrus demi lovato il a plein plein de
gens passent ça j'en passe et des
meilleurs alors ça c'est bon pas et soit
dit
bah oui c'est vrai absolument c'est vrai
c'est vrai l'actrice met l'un noir
moi je connaissais pas du tout je disais
oui pourquoi
non mais parce que la manière dont vous
l'avez dit
laxisme est un droit non alan ward sol
riche panel en plus en angleterre
connu pour son rôle de rachel mcguire
d'âge ou pas du coup je respecte pas la
jeu dans la série incorrigible cauris
tout ce que je dis pas ce que je dis
bien de sortir son proche des films
pornographiques sans revanche les vu le
film s'appelle driver le 4 octobre
dernier
donc voilà alors pour l'infâme tour de
table pourquoi certaines stars de disney
partent en vrille comme ça parce qu on
sait qu effectivement il ya beaucoup de
stars de l'estey britney spears est là
les petits sociaux par an soit elles
font des cures de désintox soit derrière
se retrouve comme miley cyrus sur une
grosse boule en train de danser
oui c'est à s'attaquer de pardon à ces
questions voilà sur sa peau qu'elle
démarre petit tout formaté avec 4 doigts
on n'a pas dissipé après elle se
retrouve avec trop disait donc c'est la
question pourquoi est ce qu'elle parte
en vrille comme ça est ce que quelqu'un
veut prendre la parole sur ce sujet
qu'il connaît bien ah bah évidemment
quand par le sexe yao quand tu veux
entre une miss france qui partit dans le
porno un châle signalé ah bon pas encore
basset qui elle alors mais vivre encore
un peu de temps chez rythme et en fait
il paraît que d'après les psychanalystes
le milieu de disney tellement et c6 et
fait rire du coup quand tu dis d'après
les psychanalystes et là que je sens que
j'ai 100 matches et qui s'y risquent
mais lorsque mieux
et du coup on fait le milieu est
tellement aseptisée que et ben comme en
plus on l son adolescente évadés qui dès
qu'elles sortent de ça et bien elles
prennent un virage tracks je pense pas
que ce soit ça avait entre le regard
complètement creux et les seins trop
important
féret et on ne peut pas penser à
quelqu'un tu à 37 ans on dirait sa soeur
est du coup très bien c'est que magritte
du coup il est content d'en lire c'est
un compliment
comme avec des gros seins merci pas
retenu mon âge et que t'as pas dû 38,7
fait sens très souriante et des amis on
peut reprendre
quand on est adolescent si on a des
parents super stricte et moi qu'est ce
qu'on va faire on va faire des bêtises
eh bien là c'est pareil en fait elles
sont un moment annoncé sa route alors un
an mais en vrai sur galerie on dit
toujours britney spears et lindsay lohan
et miley cyrus
en fait il ya aussi dicaprio vaquer
france et loana ryan gosling faille à la
plaque on m'appelle cannes est au cinéma
bien sûr c'est un défi surtout des
filles c'est pas tous en même temps pas
tous en même temps son gardien
transition très jeune quand même ils
sont les super gamins ils sont projetés
aux amis enfin incroyable et après ils
dérapent ils font les portes aux médias
d'alcooliques veut dire ouais c'est pas
évident à vivre